so
it's actually good but it's like [ __ ]
hot yes it's delicious
no it's really good i'm in
what do you think about these cute cats
they're super cute
the game of thrones
how are you feeling i'm feeling fine i'm
just looking for my coffee
we still don't have my coffee
another terrace
it's more this is so nice more rustic
oh my friend
love peace
i'm actually taking a video you know so
you can stop
pretending you're cute how do you feel
i want to go there are you going to swim
iman
no i'm going to lie now swing soon
let's go
i mean the sun is setting but
like i am always the person who's making
stupid things stupid comments
i mean why do you think
[Music]
it is hard you look crazy
is it good
[Music]
but i wanted to make a nice video like
you just are going too closer to the
water
and then you're just one and one hand
with us like also the koka bottom
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
can you explain to me what actually
happened nah
like like what happens to your humanity
yeah i kinda i i felt like very very
disgusted and i still felt like respect
for me like
it disappeared like even the little bit
i had there
it's not there anymore yeah same but
well
i feel good
[Music]
i want to see the first it's taste
actually see
actually yeah it's actually yeah how is
it good
[Music]
[Music]
you